how's how's that what I was gonna say
how's everything else but we don't have
time to catch up on personal life Lauren
Francesca we have no personal life it is
only YouTube YouTube YouTube
nothing else matters in life we don't
vacation we don't travel and we don't
hang out we only networked that's how
you live a happy life people guys the
Superbowl was this weekend I don't know
if you caught it but I missed a couple
of commercials I gotta check out the
tide one but she already watched it on
her channel check out the channel I want
my Lauren is that the one it's on yeah
Oh Jay I have a channel I want my Lauren
also she did a web series that I have a
guest appearance in along with my
brother Jabba ko ha ha and it's the
first episode of the webseries a planned
haven't seen it yet we will do a
reaction to it for this channel oh yeah
it wants to react to the whole thing or
just the first episode see myopathy my
15 seconds of fame my literal 15 seconds
guys we're gonna watch the monster
Superbowl commercial today the extended
edition you know you got so much more
camera space here I'm like off to the
side and it's like not fair to me I mean
if we're both like awkwardly leaning
like this I get scoliosis all right no
we're good we're good you could sit
however you want and sorry to make you
self-conscious about the way you're
sitting
[Music]
it's the right stuff I don't know
Oh rice go that is rice gum right I
don't know I don't know rice gum man
it's like he's the monster like a serial
killer it's going on to see what he did
I heard about it
oh oh maybe he's gonna see that girl
yeah I don't I don't know famous people
[Music]
yeah like she would cuts monster oh it's
a you got to make that clear on your
title people out that we're gonna watch
a high-octane energy drink commercial
apparently there's some headphones out
here that are amazing who are the
feature people in this is that rice gum
wait do we like rice gum I forget does
the YouTube world like rice come do you
know rice gum you know a lot more people
than I know one of his like podcasts
before he blew up Oh was he nice then he
was nice his fans were a little is he do
you still talk to him no I haven't
talked to him what's your opinion of
rice gum I think he's cool I mean I
don't know I think a lot of people they
get youtube famous and they like you
know they just get youtube famous but I
mean hey he's getting commercials he's
getting a Super Bowl commercial that is
huge
that's more than YouTube famous right
there good for this guy do you think
like this was supposed to go to Logan
Paul and then they were like okay
No maybe I might be pretty funny is that
you use a Lea yeah you know that for
sure I think for sure and if you look at
the comments I saw you flash at comments
for a second it said yeah I mean I'm not
for sure for sure but it looks like Iggy
Azalea this is like one of the better
directed storytelling Superbowl
commercials we've seen it's not like
funny or something it's not that but
there's an actual story that's going on
here I don't really have an opinion on
rice gum I don't know jack about the guy
honestly I don't really know Iggy Azalea
either but in terms of a storytelling
two-and-a-half minute commercial I
actually appreciated it it's this lonely
guy in a subway who gets lost in the
transportation of music creates these
headphones so he can really let his mind
go free and see where his heart goes
with that because I like stories that do
anything along the lines of letting
music transport you to another realm
transfer you to another version of
reality so I thought it was really
heartfelt in in a weird way I don't know
how people are actually responding this
commercial I personally liked it it made
me want to buy these monster headphones
I wonder who that could be no jabs Kawai
probably yeah he doesn't like to send me
a message before he shows up even though
he does the same exact channel I do he's
just like I'm gonna buzz in Casey's
filming interrupted no it's just
recording and were filming yep
Jamie Kawai people yeah I mean I don't
really care for the song I know what you
think Lauren I I was just excited cuz I
heard he was in a Superbowl commercial I
was like damn I missed it but then I got
to see it yeah it was in a two so I'm
kind of jealous I'm like wow he met her
yeah well it does nothing to show me
what makes these monster headphones
better than any other headphones other
than a couple of famous people are using
them in this commercial and what can I
say
famous people have a way to influence me
and persuade me into doing things I
don't know anything about thanks Ryan
Gosling for getting me into cigarettes
for a couple years
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell anytime you
want toilet flush Jabby Kawai takes the
fastest poops you'll ever hear
I want my lord her channel I want my
Lauren channel check out the show
application with javi Kuwait on the
Jericho a channel take care of people